okay so our next talk is about
Hamiltonian simulation on a quantum
computer and
alright thank you for the introduction
so today my talk will be about optimal
Hamiltonian simulation an algorithm that
you can run on a digital quantum
computer so this is one of my advisor
MIT so let me quote what John fresco
said earlier this week
whatever you say about quantum
information or processing as a statement
about physics I really like this because
I think that the converse is also true
whatever you say about physics is a
statement about quantum information and
processing so this talk we look at very
simple physics take it as far as we can
and see what kind of statement and makes
about quantum processing and this state
- quantum signal processing which when
applied to the Hamiltonian simulation
problem then said we are a very nice
final ingredient that closes a gap
between upper and upper bounds in the
query model so the connection between
physics and computation is very
well-known for example physical concepts
can inspire general problem-solving
methods for example you have adiabatic
evolution and quantum walks these are
universal for quantum computation but
confining any specific algorithm to
these architectures can lead to very
large overheads or sometimes even wipe
out the polynomial improvements which
means that they are not really practical
for the quantum computers of today so an
alternate approach has arisen which is
to use physical systems directly to
solve computational problems for example
we have bosons sampling which computes
the matrix permanence using a physical
system of linear objects directly and we
also have recently more innovative
methods for Hamiltonian simulation by
directly implementing your design
Hamiltonian in a physical system so this
is the analog quantum simulator
these physical approaches to computing
are very elegant they are very simple
and they are very fast because they make
a direct connection the problem you are
trying to solve so as a result of very
small overheads very small constant
factor overheads which means that there
are actually candidates for very near
term quantum computing device
however one issue that they face is that
they are not quite as scalable as a
universal quantum computer because they
are hard to make fault tolerance so we
would like to merge the best of these
two votes we would like to still
maintain the very small constant
overheads of exploiting physical systems
to perform computations maintain the
intuition of how they perform which aids
our understanding and how algorithms
work and in doing so perhaps the final
algorithm should be simple and very fast
and we would like to also perform this
map in a way that is compatible with
foreign compute from the computation so
this is the idea of quantum signal
processing the abstraction of physical
dynamics into a computing module which
we call a quantum signal processor that
allows us to do all that so now I'm
going to the outline of my talk now
briefly talk about what the Hamiltonian
simulation problem is and previous work
on this view I will then give an
overview of the quadrant Hamiltonian
simulation algorithm that we have
invented and how quantum signal
processing applies to it and then I'll
conclude so the Hamiltonian simulation
problem is a very simple question we
have a description of a Hamiltonian of a
quantum system and we would like to
simulate its time evolution operator so
what this means is that we would like to
implement the time evolution operator a
unitary on a quantum state with small
error so this is a very useful and
important question because nature's
based on physics if we can solve this
problem we can say Civic chemistry
materials may be my machines leave
simulate the Big Bang it is also a very
common primitive and many quantum
algorithms and some algorithms are
naturally expressed as a time
independent Hamiltonian such as quantum
walks and spent row grams so by now
you've probably seen this quote by
Richard Feynman about four times but
that's because it's a really good quote
the Hamiltonian simulation problem is
hard because nature is on classical
nature is one
one intuitive way to understand wireless
hard is the curse of dimensionality if
you have n qubits the number of
parameters parameters you have to track
in your state space skills exponentially
with the size of your system now over
the hamiltonian simulation problem for
time independent Hamiltonian is
universal and so if we could solve this
on a classical computer I think we will
need to find new jobs alright so the
difficulty of implementing this time
evolution operates on a quantum computer
very much depends on the assumptions we
make on the input for example our
Hamiltonian was still presented to us as
a list of exponentially many classical
numbers our quantum computer wouldn't
help we either need a description at a
sparse so poly logarithmic number terms
in the dimension of the system or we
need a quantum way to specify a
description of this I'm at onion so
there are a few major input models the
first workable algorithm for having your
simulations by satellite they considered
Hamiltonians that can be decomposed into
a sum of local interactions where each
local interaction is easy to simulate
and only acts on a constant number
qubits this very naturally describes
many physical systems and provides an
intuitive way to see how Hamiltonian
simulation can be done so using ground
own product formulas such as Trotter
ization we can simulate time evolution
of the Sun by a product of time
evolution of the components and as we
have more Exponential's the error goes
down but so does the time of simulation
go up so this was generalized with the
Espace hamiltonian model where we have a
Hamiltonian which is a matrix of numbers
and at most D nonzero entries in heavy
row so this can be related to the
previous model when D is depends on K in
that formula proportional to the number
of terms and exponential a
dimensionality of support so since
there's no current principal contain
exponentially many numbers we need a
quantum way to provide information
on this matrix this is commonly done by
assuming access Oracle's that compute
the positions of nonzero column indices
and also an another arm code that
provides the value of these nonzero
elements so one reason why this is a
popular model is because it is commonly
used in the design of quantum operators
based on quantum box and can sometimes
be used to clean exponential speed ups
when DSP logger makino dimensionality
such as Q is P for matrix inversion a
more recent model introduced is the
unitary access model where instead of a
sum of local interactions where each
interaction is a hermitian matrix we
have us have a twin that is a linear
combination of unitary operators this
requires a different or ago but is
notable because it does better than all
of the product formula cultures use for
key local interactions and it's very
promising for the simulation of physical
systems so let's look at some of the
prior work that has gone into this a
brief history of simulation we all knew
that the Big Bang began in 1982 because
that's when our career started with
Richard Feynman and after the Dark Ages
lasting about 10 years satellite came
out the first work about quantum
simulation algorithm so you can see here
the skills for the normally and the
number of terms M and the error and also
the time so this led to an inflation of
many new approaches to simulate
Hamiltonians where you have product
formulas that increase the scaling
respect to sparsity time and error and
in the last result in 2010 we see how
additional structure about Hamiltonian
can be incorporated if you know more
about it like say if some of the
components have a larger non than the
others so this was further improved by
the unitary access model which well it
doesn't quite use the same inputs
achieves much better scaling than
product formulas and so it's something
that's been developed extensively in
recent years then parallel techniques
for simulations are simultaneous opposes
gdb progress and you can see the the
scalar query complexity
has improved with respect to the
sparsity D and the dimensionality so
it's gone from poly blocker
I mean putty and d 2 d 4 and D cubed and
the dependence on dimensionality is
Rockstar which is basically a very small
constant factor all of this was improved
by one victory result by Andrew Calais
where he designed quantum walk at like
about any Hamiltonian and by just using
by querying the deepest Oracle's here
chief of the more time scaling and both
no it's not optimal scaling above the
time and sparsity in but unfortunately
the screen and respect to era is
significantly worse than the product
formula approaches so now we enter the
modern era and the breakthrough reserve
and the last two years was by Dominic
berry include charles richard lee from
in Caesarea and Rolando samah so there
they found an alternate approach for the
dispersed model that has of the most
scaling and just era but unfortunately
the scaling of respect with time is not
quite linear but very close this is also
similarly generalized to the unitary
access model and more recently they are
the paper achieving nearly optimal
dependence of our parameters that the
chief of scary that's the product of
time and something that's basically
logarithmic an error so this is just a
multiplicative factor away from the
lower bound which they also proved in
that paper so last year we finally
managed to close the gap between upper
and lower bounds we still use the same
ideas of the quanta Bach developed by
Andrew Charles but we use that as a
subroutine in our quantum signal
processing module and this turns out to
be the final media to close the gap
between upper and lower bounds so our
approach is somewhat more specialized
than the techniques used by previous
work but we managed to generalize it
more recently to the unitary access
model with an open model that can deal
with these two are of course a special
cases
Peregrin Dominic berry and novo they
further you find the our techniques to
achieve skating close to the lower
balance so no the scaling a slightly
worse but there are ideas have merit
because in a sense there are techniques
are more flexible and could be
applicable to other problems like
time-dependent simulation so now let's
give an overview of how our algorithm
works we use consider the the sparse
input model we will not be talking about
qubit ization in the rest of this talk
in this input model we assume access to
two articles we have the column Oracle
which if you feed in the row index I and
a number L spits out the elf nonzero
column index the Alpha column index of
the column index of the Alpha nonzero
matrix elements we also have another
Oracle the element Orrico that one
feeding in a row and column index fixer
spits out the matrix element of your
Hamiltonian the goal of this is to
output the time evolution operator and
our algorithm works by first
implementing the discrete time quantum
walk for any Hamiltonian invented by
Charles so this quantum walk is very
nice because using just a constant
number of queries to this are opposed
the implements exact time evolution but
with a Hamiltonian that has a modified
spectrum from the desired Hamiltonian
the difference is by a function arcsine
so we want to linearize this we do so
using our quantum signal processing
techniques where we find a physical
system that very naturally solves the
problem of eigen phase transformations
and so if we were to implement eigen
phase transformation by a sinusoid
composing up sine we have sine results
in identity and so this linearizes the
time evolution operator and gives us our
desired simulation algorithm and since
the quantum walk takes a constant of our
queries the complexity of this final
approach is entirely dependent on the
quantum signal processing module and
this very complexity turns out to be
linear and time sparsity the maximum
absolute value of any entry in your
matrix
and as edited with the design era of
performing this transformation so
because early on I claimed that physical
systems they are in a sense closer to
the computational problem with small
overheads so maybe they are simpler and
this turns out to be the case we only
use a single and sudah qubit which means
that this could be a very good candidate
for a small quantum computer so how does
this work I claim that we use very
simple physics and what could be simpler
than a single qubit unitary so here I
have a single qubit rotation you could
visualize it as a rotation on the Bloch
sphere about the x axis by some angle
theta and as you change angle you
implement a different gate so how can
you use this compute I think the answer
depends on who you ask if you were to
ask somebody about some quantum
computation they would say that's choose
theta and perhaps implement universe so
discreet gates like IX and with perhaps
other rotations the Hodari and T gate
somebody works on quantum metrology
might think perhaps we could apply this
estate and compute an estimate of theta
that's a form of computation and
somebody about some quantum control my
also wonder well can do we have the
flexibility to really choose the
rotation angle or the input state so
here we combine all of these ideas ready
this is just a restatement of the
definition of unitary matrix but I think
it's worth praising it this way the
single qubit rotation is a computational
module that computes some function some
unitary function that depends on the
input parameter which may or may not be
under your control
the input state and the measurement
basis so to give an example of what this
means let us multiply a bunch of these
rotations together and apply it to the 0
state and projecting to those real state
so this computes the function cosine n
theta which I have plotted there this
seems like neat but it doesn't seem very
useful sinusoids
like alright I guess I thought but what
could you do with it so clearly if you
want to use this to solve interesting
problems we need to be able
to compute interesting functions we do
this by assuming that we can introduce
more control parameters so that sandwich
our X rotation about two phase rotations
which we have control over so now if we
consider sequence of these single qubit
rotations for some choice of phases we
see that they can compute more
interesting functions so they're not
three different functions for random
choices of phases and you could maybe
imagine that some good choice of five
could do something really interesting
like computer thresholding function or
maybe control computer spike function so
the idea here is that our single qubit
processor is a string of unitary
functions and our control parameters the
face is like example o'clock code that
we run on this processor to compute a
unitary function since this is a single
qubit unitary we can decompose it into
the poly basis and the coefficients are
functions that you would like to design
and we can then select the desired
functions or their linear combination by
some of your choice of input state and
basis measurements so you know this
seems interesting maybe but maybe might
be obvious why is this a heart problem
or why happen anybody done this before
this is because it is actually very hard
to design this the best analogy is with
the single qubit gates in this problem
so until say three or four years ago
single qubit gates ancestors could only
be solved in exponential time they've
got to the final of the mo decomposition
into a basis discrete gate set so there
you have a matrix of numbers your
unitary matrix and you want to decompose
it into a string of other matrices the
single qubit processor considers a
modified version of this question we
said have a single qubit unitary
function so this is not the matrix of
numbers it is a matrix of functions and
we want to decompose it into a basis set
of unitary functions rather than unitary
gates and this is us control sequence
that has been studied for decades and
feels like NMR so we have built up a
massive amount of intuition on what
because
possibly deliver but designing and
optimal sequence has often been an
expansion exponentially haha because the
best augur does is actually a man to
doing a best fit to your target
functions by gradient descents
so recently we solve this problem by
finding necessary sufficient constraints
on worse choices of these functions so
what we'll focus on today is designing
the coefficients of the identity and the
expo atoms and the quote constraints on
what we can choose for these functions
actually quite intuitive when our matrix
when our rotation angle is zero we
implement an identity rotation so a
sequence of identity gates is just
identity and that means the coefficients
of the identity operator that must be
one theta equals zero and similarly
probabilities must be bounded so the sum
of squares of any of these terms must be
less than one and if you perform a
direct expansion you find that a and C
are no more than a for a series so this
is quite cool because the first series
they are they form a complete basis for
your functions on bounded intervals so
in principle you could approximate or
implement any arbitrary function you
want with less officially long sequence
of similar gates and we also provided an
efficient algorithm to show how you can
compute and poly end-time the synthesis
of a similar cubic function into its
component gates given some for a series
a and C so now we have a systematic
methodology for actually doing something
useful with single qubit processor but
it is not clear how this is applicable
to general quantum algorithms this is a
single qubit operator quantum algorithms
interesting ones
Motty cubed operators the first obvious
step would be to perhaps find quantum
algorithms that are naturally isomorphic
to ask you to but these are limited or
perhaps not as exciting in fact some
folk over such as one of them so the
solution to this is to recognize that we
are not interested in literally applying
this you are interested and treating
this as an abstracted quantum
computation or module so vo finds
yourself use this and try to expand its
utility by
say appending it to elijah system so
let's consider and then sila state that
is a single qubit and a system state
that could have many qubits and let's
put our single qubit processor in the
NCR States so usually when you have an
insulin a system you would think that
the answer lock controls the system here
we take a different interpretation the
single qubit rotation operator is
controlled by our system meaning that
the angle of rotation in each of those
primitive rotations depends on the state
you feed into the system to see how this
is possible let's look at an arbitrary
unitary matrix W if some eigenstates
lambda and some I can't faze us and let
us look at the controlled version we
create this controlled version where if
you feed it a plastic to the ancilla
you get identity on the system and your
feelin - on the end sooner you get the
eigen phase you get W on the system so
when you feed on an eigen state you
decouple the to the eigen State remains
unchanged but in the single qubit line
you implemented your single qubit
rotation so now let's replace all of
those rotations about the x axis by this
control W rotation and now we find that
if you feed on an eigen state the single
qubit processor if you apply it to the
plus state and the insulin project on
the plasti amounts to applying a
function on a function on the eigen
State lambda so this is like changing
the coefficients of lambda and the value
of this coefficient depends on the eigen
phase of lambda so now you can kind of
see how maybe this could be used to
perform eigen phase transformations we
can choose the row and imaginary
components of this coefficient - perhaps
match complex phase factor that depends
on the rotation angle theta and how do
we do this let us choose some objective
function for our eigen phase
transformations so this is H theta it is
a periodic function that map's a circle
for a circle and we want to approximate
the
complex face factor with a complex
series of DB n so n will determine the
number of single qubit rotations and if
n determines the number one trait abuse
which in turn determines the number of
Oracle queries to our element and column
Oracle's so this 50 much and highly
determines a high complexity of
Hamiltonian simulation so the first step
is to find a good approximation to this
complex space factor so you find two
first series that approximated some
error epsilon in general if you're in
general some choice of this
approximation may not satisfy the
constraints which represent an earlier
example perhaps equal square to be
greater than one but it's easy to
compute on these and achievable modified
set of functions sir approximate the
face factor to only a slightly larger
error but is achievable so now if we
substitute these transformations into
the coefficients we see that by applying
this single qubit processor but the
rotation angles country by the system we
can implement on eigenstates our desired
I got phase transformation the
complexity of this depends on details of
the target function for example if the
target function is smooth you get a
polynomial screening of error if it's
analytic you get exponential error and
if it's entire you get super logarithmic
error the target function for
Hamiltonian simulation is an entire
function which is why we get the scaling
that we see because the very complexity
for any target n is very good so as you
can see here this approximates the these
are face factor with at recesses that
depends on the initial area of your
approximating first series and because
the face factor has a norm of one if
your first series approximates this it's
access probability is also close to one
so now let's apply this so Hamiltonian
simulation the objective function for
Hamiltonian simulation is a sinusoid
because this linearize this a quantum
walk there's a very well known for a
series expansion for this objective
function the so Jacobi anga expansion
and
it is well know that if you were to
truncate a fir expansion and only kick
the first n terms you get essentially
the best approximation so by doing so
you can compute the approximation error
by summing over the terms you do not
consider and because this is a soup and
this is an entire function the scalar
with arizuka exponential rather than
just exponential so this allows us to
solve for the complexity as a function
of the simulation time tau which you see
in that J is actually a Bessel function
and the target error and this core
complexity measures lower bounds derived
by the authors for where they got it by
finding a time independent Hamiltonian
that solves a priority problem so you
can see that the error scaling before
solving for n of the quantum signal
processing procedure and that of the
lower bound are very similar they need a
third by a factor of e over two inside
that's below that exponent and actually
if you were to evaluate the truncation
error numerically that constant factor
disappears so that's really cool because
this is an algorithm that appears also
be optimum up to constant factors so one
I think that by solving the query
complexity of these paths simultaneous
emulation we have kind of ended a few
that's highly the case got more like in
a big rip of habit in a simulation where
the number of questions are rapidly
expanding you have any other problems
remaining for example we have software
complexity but what really matters in
the end of gate complexity or simulation
to determine whether is practical
they're also the interesting questions
like can defendant simulation which our
technique doesn't handle well but the
techniques by Dominick very Andover
could do and we all serve the simulation
of quantum systems which is very
interesting because operative systems in
nature are open so the for some very
nice recent work in the poster sessions
earlier this week that this and also
very nice work for Hamiltonians where
you are given my a priori information
about a structure for example whether
the submitted atoms come you rather than
just having a list of Hamiltonian says
no other information so the other
another very interesting direction which
could be realized in their futures and a
lock simulation and there
very interesting talk I think by Stefan
fed up later today afternoon
yeah fever came out last night and I
think it's exciting so we also
introduced this new query model for
Hamilton a simulation that apparently
use of the deepest input and the three
access input so perhaps this could be
used to solve other interesting input
models that allow us to realize quantum
speedups and by freezing the problem
differently
so in conclusion my hope I've convinced
you that we have a few that is
interesting and actionable that arises
by combining ideas and quantum actually
control and algorithms control control
arises because we choose a control
policy to implement some desire unitary
function metrology arises because we
select the components of this unitary
function of some choice of states and
some measurement bases and algorithm
arises because we treat this unitary
evolution there at Lee as a computation
of audio so together we have looked at
what happens if you take a single qubit
system and abstract it this way so very
natural question so be what if you were
to look at more complicated systems like
to keep interaction and so analog
simulator swattin problems with a
naturally solve if you were to just look
at the other hand a mix and so since I
quote John fresco area but I haven't
been any black host for this conference
I have a black over there and maybe you
could think about what kind of quantum
information processing would we be doing
if we had control over black Jose by
jumping in every now and then what
problem with this solve and maybe it
could lead to some deep insights about
how we like physics and computation so
if you're interested in some of the
ideas that went into this I have other
work now there that focus on the results
related to the secure qubit processor
and if you were to look at that might be
very happy all right thank you
okay so we have lots of time for
questions okay thank you sir yes may be
different from some of the previous
algorithms on quantum simulation I guess
your algorithm requires some kind of
classical computation like computing the
angles for the irrotational operators
right that's right yeah so I guess and
in practice such kind of calculations
might be carried out numerically so I
guess um
I just wondered do you have any feelings
of the performance of you know such
classical calculations so the nice thing
about these classifications is that we
only need to perform them once so if you
wanted to simulate the Hamiltonian for
any time T you will compute the string
of phasers and for any other Hamiltonian
simulation problem you could use the
same string of phasers to simulate for
the same amount of time T so so in any
case the computation can be done in
polynomial time so this is just a
classic Oh overhead the majestic dowon's
is easy and not need to worry about in
the future
other questions
can you give us a natural system which
is given which is described by suppose
Hamiltonian
so I mentioned key local interactions
idea they describe many physical systems
across most physical systems are local
and you can always describe a keylock
accessibility space animal Tony on and
because your key local interaction so
any external concern number of qubits
the sparsity is going to be bounded
times the number of terms in your local
interactions so that's a natural system
okay
it's possible I'm confused you your
result is about query complexity that's
right right so but you also talked about
overhead and implementing it on a small
quantum computers so right so how would
you implement the oracle if you were
doing this as an actual
that's an excellent question I guess I
forgot to mention the CAF yet it is
extremely small overhead beyond the
complexity required to implement the
Oracle some Arcos are easy to implement
some are cosa hard is actually a very
active field of research every now and
then you see papers talking about
implementing very sparse articles and
this is why the unitary access model is
so appealing because the Oracles are
very simple physical rotations rather
than being composed of some large
sequence of single and two qubit gates
so the unitary access model is a great
candidate for realizing in the small
corner computers and our techniques can
now view of that we still have time for
more questions Nathan
so one of the things that you were
discussing is the inability of this
method to cut simulate time-dependent
Hamiltonian which is inherited from it's
sort of legacy of being based in quantum
walks so I was wondering if you could
talk about you know how you specifically
why this is a problem and if there's
potentially any way forward to address
it all right so we live in a universe
that's modern mechanical and our
universe may or may not be closed its
inmates probably closed because maybe at
some point you get to a large enough
scope as I mean racketing is closed but
nevertheless we are still interacting in
a time-dependent way you know like in
this conference so clearly there is some
way to encode meaningful time-dependent
interactions in a time independent
Hamiltonian and this is an idea that has
been explored a lot in thermodynamics
for example autonomous heat engines and
I think there's a deep link between
Hamiltonian simulation in a
time-dependent case and quondam
thermodynamics
oh here so for single qubit get the
composition we know there's a solid
Khattab algorithm so a your quiz on for
the single cricket decomposition is
either exponentially better than the
salariki to have a versa
they are incomparable the soul of a
guitar algorithm can be applied to the
single qubit function synthesis problem
but only in a very restricted case so
the other application of syllabic of a
guitar is for synthesizing a Saluki they
gave him a discrete gate set and that's
a different problem basically you can
really apply sort of a guitar to the
question we consider here of a general
way to synthesize a unitary function
from a unitary basis set of functions
how about this do you have a some
intuitive explanation how the scaling
ways that a tips alone is a power log
right let's look at I think this is this
is related to deep results and pure
mathematics and approximation theory I
don't really have a good intuitive
explanation why but the math just says
that when your functions are smooth you
can approximate it better with functions
that vary and when your function is
really really smooth like analytic you
can even more easily approximated by
functions that very such as sine waves
and so the smoothness and analyticity
determine how the iris kills is the
number of terms you use to sum up to
approximate this function i think that's
the best sounds like and good
so oh thanks it thanks again for a
second question um one of the things I'm
also kind of curious about is of course
your algorithm ends up scaling with a
max norm of a Hamiltonian that's right
so if you're putting this forward as a
as an approach to simulate physical
systems how would you go about
simulating something like the Coulomb
potential there are a few important
differences between that problem and the
dispersed problem the first issue is the
Coulomb potential acts on a continuous
basis of quantum states so there be what
first need to find a way to reasonably
truncate this row space of course
emitted refer discrete basis maybe that
could be a way to do so that loss
there's a small error but maybe you
couldn't but I suppose that you could
then we will need to think about how you
could approximate unbounded operators
with say these parts time atonia and
these are mod operator serve area - max
norms so maybe the solution has to find
a different basis where maybe the
Coulomb potential can be easily
separated into low energy and energy
components and this is why I think the
recent paper for the top light on analog
simulation is interesting because they
describe a method to perform such a
splitting of high energy and energy
subspaces okay let's let's think going
how again for a great talk
you